[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
episode
291 today with a special guest
for some that don't know he's a viral
internet sensation actor and Empire and
Shameless uh he's got a hit white boy
summer and then he went viral for
talking uh Patois right and then famous
for his anti-vaccine rant famous for
anti-trump Brands and his father is a
winner I believe of Black Jeopardy right
Doug he from SNL who happens to be also
Tom Hanks Chet thank you so much for
being a guest on the podcast man thank
you for having me you got a lot of stuff
you've done man you got your uh all over
the place with your opinions your
thoughts your you know creativity yeah
I've been pretty outspoken how do you
feel about that well some of it some of
the things I've been outspoken about I
have a different opinion on now
you know things are always changing
sometimes you speak on something at one
point and
you uh you know it's 20 20 hindsight so
you don't you couldn't you can't know at
the time how things are going to pan out
so you know sometimes your opinions
change but one thing that hasn't changed
is I've always been uh pretty open about
my opinions on things if I feel like I
have something to say that I don't
really have a problem using my voice
that's that's great but I'd be curious
to know what opinions have changed by
the way because with you I got a lot of
topics I want to get into you know I got
you know your own self on how to create
your own identity being in the uh a
Family household that you were raised in
I'm sure that's like the main topic
people want to talk to you about uh your
your families you know somehow some way
always tied to not always recently maybe
in the last two and a half years uh tied
to conspiracy theories and then at the
same time you seem very loose you seem
very comfortable in your own skin uh
when you go out you're doing what you're
doing so you were saying some things
have changed I gave the intro and right
off the bat the first thing you said is
some opinions have changed what has
changed oh that's a good question let's
get right into it um
specifically like when you mentioned
that I was uh against Trump
right well what you're talking about is
a video I posted also in a Jamaican
accent when Trump lost the election and
I said boss man Biden beat Trump and
whatnot
I still the reasons I was against Trump
at that time have not changed you know
the like specifically you know the
racist stuff
it's debatable you know people got their
own opinions on whether he's actually
racist but I'm talking about the
comments of like you know there's good
people on both sides when talking about
the neo-nazis that's the stuff that made
me be against Trump at the time but at
that time when Biden won the election I
was big enough Biden and my feelings of
Biden
um have changed
so you don't have the same this is the
most popular president we've ever had 81
million votes your opinions on him has
changed on Biden yeah yeah
in what way I mean well
does it look like this country is going
well
you know there's uh the economy is you
know absolute [ __ ] that in La there's
homeless people everywhere yeah
I mean they're just doing drugs out on
the streets
we gave all that money to Ukraine for
what
we uh we our economy don't we have
enough problems to take care of within
our own country
rather than go spending all our tax
dollars giving it to some other country
while we have homelessness everywhere
it's rampant and we're giving out crack
pipes to people
yeah but isn't that an LA problem like
is that something that your boy Newsome
has to kind of clean up or Garcetti this
is also New York though that's also
Illinois though that's also you know
Portland
Seattle what Portland came out and said
yesterday did you hear about that Tyler
did you hear what the Portland guy said
yesterday we got to figure this out this
homelessness problem is is bad you know
the too many drugs out there and what
are you talking about these are the
byproducts of your policy I mean it
boggles my mind Gavin Newsom is even in
office I mean it's almost as if you had
a governor there who was his job was to
just have everything go to [ __ ] as much
as possible it's almost like that's his
objective like how can I [ __ ] up this
state as much as possible
that's what it looks like he crushed it
in the recall what was that in 2020 2021
and it wasn't even there against Larry
Elder doesn't make any sense to me that
that also goes for the mayor of La I
mean I mean it's all it's all absolute
[ __ ] yeah you know I've I've grown up
I've been born and raised in La my
entire life I've never seen anything
like this when did it start really
getting bad because it didn't start
during covet it got exponentially words
during coven
as I'm sure it was like in a lot of
cities all across America
also the stuff in the vaccine I just
don't agree with I think it's morally
wrong I don't feel like people should be
forced to take anything
I think it's absolutely insane why do
you well here's the question though
should you come across as a you you have
a very different experience in life than
the average person you've seen a lot
okay in your life and at a very young
age so to you a nice car to an average
gamer oh my God that's a Lamborghini
you'd like to just I've seen the cars
you've seen this incorrect that's
incorrect you still value that you'll
still see me
this is this is like the the number one
misconception about me and my upbringing
that like I I was just you know given
Lamborghinis or that's not what I'm
saying that's right no but but still
like a Lamborghini like this is what
people don't understand is that like for
the majority of my life I've been
absolutely broke like I mean like living
paycheck to paycheck like throughout my
early 20s I mean throughout like you
know up until my late 20s
when I started when my acting career
started taking off and I was making
enough money to support myself so I
didn't have to work at nine to five yeah
I mean if I had like you know 700 in my
bank account then that was like a lot of
money
you know what I'm saying like for the
majority of my life up until my mid-20s
instead in in until I started getting
you know consistent recurring roles or
series regulars on TV shows but I guess
the point I'm trying to make and I I
appreciate you saying that I think one
part you said you know might I would
tell my dad that I need some money would
say go wash my car here 60 bucks right
so you always have to earn based on what
you said the way you were raised I
actually think you were raised the right
way by hey we have the money but this
doesn't mean me too but what I'm saying
is you've been on the Jets you've been
around the celebrity you've been on the
Hollywood people you've seen all these
guys they're regular people that come to
your house I'm assuming that's the life
you were around so you but you're also
in a space where if I'm if let's just
say I'm your you know my father's a
general of the army who am I going to be
around military guys vets Colonels
officers you know that's my world so I
understand military that's the world I
come from so my language is yes sir this
and maybe I hate it maybe it's too much
like stop cleaning my bed in the morning
I don't clean my bed there's going to be
some kind of resentment towards a
military background right you hear
something or or if my father was a
pastor of a big church and I got caught
smoking weed and the next Sunday morning
the pastor I remember being at church
when my pastor's son got caught doing
something and he had to talk about it on
stage 20 000 members not comfortable so
the pressure of being the son of a
preacher's boy we've read about it we've
you know you've seen it all over the
place where there's certain pressures
that comes with it but you know the
Bible studies you know all that's
because that's your world same with
athletes you know Michael Jordan's son
you know he's got the shadow of his
father and you know he's trying to you
know there's no way in the world you're
going to match that shadow
for you
you're in a family where the last name
is Hanks it's Tom Hanks and your mom's
also an actress and they both made it to
the top but your dad's in the goat
status he's one of the greatest of all
time to do what he's done I know you
talk about what agrees until today gets
him emotional gives you emotion when you
talk about some of the movies you know
but for you to say what you just said
about Biden what you just said about
California about Newsome comfortably the
way that you did
and then in that world most of them
support what Newsome does most of them
supported the shutdown most of them
supported the vaccine most of them
supported
how do you how do you is that a battle
you deal with or no you're pretty
comfortable with your position and hey
this is who I am
I'd rather be hated for who I am Than
Love For Whom I'm not
have you always been like that
not always
but uh
as I get older I uh
I just feel that that's important
I mean I I I can't be anybody other than
who I am
you know
I could yeah you could you could be who
you are of just you could omit you know
what I'm saying I could be who I am and
just not say that you know but we're
having a discussion you know I could
just omit that but then isn't it kind of
a liable Mission if I choose not to say
something that I really believe I mean
we're on a podcast I'm with you you're
you know I already know coming into this
this is going to be an extremely
intelligent discussion this is a type of
platform for extremely intelligent
discussions I haven't mentioned this but
I mean it's such a privilege to be here
because I'm a huge fan of the podcast I
watched all the mafia States of America
like I love this [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying so this is a trip and it's dope
to be here having a conversation with
you I have tremendous respect for for
you and both you guys so it's really a
privilege to be here so if this is the
platform to have a a you know
intelligent discussion like that then
why wouldn't I is it uh uh is it tough
to do that is it tough to uh I guess let
me ask the question a different way so
for example a a steinburner son let's
say everybody knows the steinburner last
name you think about what the Yankees
imagine if his son is like yeah I think
baseball's you know I think I'm not a
Yankees fan
and I'm a Red Sox fan hypothetically
that's your position that's a very
dramatic position well it's interesting
right because technically I mean
politics whether you are on the left or
the right shouldn't have anything to do
with your skill set as an actor or an
Entertainer I agree so but but somehow
it's been skewed that way somehow it has
been skewed that way where if you're an
entertainment or a Hollywood then you're
only allowed to promote one side
and if you don't if you prompt the other
side at all you're like persona non
grata but at this point I mean I've
already been so [ __ ] outspoken about
anything my whole life it's like [ __ ] it
you know what I'm saying people who are
going to work with me are going to want
to work with me because I'm a talented
actor or because we have a we have a
relationship and if they don't then [ __ ]
it you know what I'm saying I I I I'm no
longer dependent on having to put all my
eggs in one basket whether it's acting
music
um or anything else I got going on
because I have something else now I have
my my myself Mastery Program my coaching
program and that's extremely fulfilling
because I get to work one-on-one with
people and uh help change their lives
you know because people have seen my
story and how I've changed my life even
though I'm still outspoken I'm sober
I got in the best shape of my life and
I'm actively pursuing something that's
benefiting people directly where I get
to work with people one-on-one and and
witness their growth and do what I can
to Aid their growth right before right
in front of my eyes because I'm not
saying I have all the answers but I but
I can say is that most of the time when
people reach out to me I know exactly
what they're going through because I've
been there Chad how old are you now I'm
32. all right um Respect by the way for
speaking your mind whether you're left
right up down middle cool do you I don't
think anybody should be blackballed or
canceled because they have beliefs
political beliefs social beliefs all
good opinions all good zero zero issues
um you said you typically were more
liberal leaning now a little bit more
conservative my entire family I mean I
was raised in a democratic family yeah
sure that's just Hollywood some people
are you know raised yeah you know in
conservative families that grow up
Republicans some people are as Democrats
okay when you're a little kid you're
going up on your family okay I went to a
school school that you know was very
conservative so I was like a minority
for having a family that was Democrats
right so like when you're a little kid
when you're in the fifth grade you know
what I'm saying when like you know Bush
was getting elected or some something
and you know you have your your little
school has like the elections right well
who are the little who's a fifth grader
voting for they're just voting for the
president that their parents are voting
for right so they don't have any opinion
on politics they're just raised a
certain a a certain way right so I was
definitely raised uh in that you know on
the left in the liberal Democratic
um you know just mindset culture
whatever but I truly consider myself a
complete moderate complete moderate I
mean I I I truly believe that honestly a
two-party system is ridiculous because
what we're having to accept now is you
either have to it's it's a it's a it's
by you know bipartisan extremes right if
you have to accept the extremes of each
of each party
even though the like the most rational
you know decision or point of view is
always going to be more in the middle do
you know what I'm saying so it's like if
you you have to you're forced to like
pick a side
and then co-sign even the most extreme
ideologies of that side
just because it's just because you're
picking the lesser of two evils but but
I honestly think that nowadays I mean
the the Republican party is a lot more
moderate than the Democratic party yeah
well they're both sides are extreme
whether you're talking about the woke
left or the absolute complete right
conspiracy right there is Maga right
right but that's moderate I think
moderate is great I'm I'm definitely in
that camp unfortunately if you're a
politician moderates don't get eyeballs
we're not eyeball culture yeah but I
feel like most people are truly moderate
you know like most people you come
across are moderate you know what I'm
saying because it's like
like like I'll speak for myself for
example okay like I believe in the the
Second Amendment okay so that's like a
like a right ideology I also believe
that women should be able to get
abortions okay that's a left ideology
okay two completely rational things that
should be like com you know like logical
but people are forced to either go out
pick one side yeah and then accept all
the stuff that comes with it so if I
want to keep my guns now I gotta be now
I gotta be re-rallying against abortions
you know what I'm saying because life
isn't black and white it's not life
isn't there's a gray area there's a
Nuance it could be liberal in some stuff
you could be conservative and others
exactly so I think that's the problem in
America today is that you're on team
blue or you're on team red yeah what
happened to red white and blue baby yeah
exactly like that's the problem in the
culture let me ask you one more
follow-up question censor seems to be a
moderate person who is more left now
you're more right there must be things
that upset you or trigger you especially
on the conspiracy side of things like
things aren't conspiracies until they're
actually proven true as an example like
freedom of speech they're limiting our
freedom of speech it's like well they
kind of are big Tech right of course
covet facts well yeah you can't trust it
it's like Well turns out you're probably
kind of could right but then you get
into crazy conspiracy things
adrenochrome you know liberal Elites you
know blood babies that's where you lose
people and you're like that just doesn't
make any sense and then you hear stories
of like your father America's dad almost
you know drinking adrenochrome you've
heard these stories of course how do you
process that
I mean it's fanciful how do I process it
I think that I think that people are
crazy freaking you know sci-fi fantasies
are a lot more interesting as an
explanation for why things are the way
they are than real life or the real
answer there it's a lot more interesting
people are bored right people are bored
in their lives it's it's it's
interesting to get lost in these crazy
theories and conspiracies instead of
like looking at like you know the this
more simple probably more more truthful
answer of why things are the way that
they are right but I don't think that
the I don't think that the left is doing
themselves any favors I mean they're
kind of the reason in promoting all
these theories because I mean just look
at Instagram okay
if you put a post on Instagram saying
anything against the vaccine it gets
flagged you might get Shadow banned it
might get removed
why is that
why is that what what interest does meta
have in promoting the vaccine why why
should they have an interest in that
they see themselves that what they claim
is they see themselves as they have the
responsibility to fact check because
they have so much influence nowadays so
they don't want people to be influenced
to think otherwise yeah but why are they
worried about people thinking otherwise
they view themselves as Arbiters of
Truth yeah but but this isn't so [ __ ]
insane I mean just think about how
insane this is
that that
we that that now the government is so
involved in our lives that they think
that and people agree that they have the
right to tell us what to inject into our
[ __ ] blood
what is that
a couple years ago before covet happened
you would have said that's [ __ ]
insane but because of the chaos and the
[ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ] that just of of
the you know people just going nuts the
the the economy tanking homelessness
everywhere you know people I have
somehow through all this chaos gotten to
the point where they go oh yeah I mean
this is normal this is normal for the
government to come tell us where we can
and can't go based upon a [ __ ]
injection this is it's not normal this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] insane Well Chad how did
you develop such strong opinions on this
because if we all remember March of
2020 the first big name that got covered
was your father Tom Hanks and nobody
knew what the [ __ ] was going on with
covert at the time if you recall and I'm
thinking I'm I'm saying as a human as a
as a fan as a person I'm thinking holy
[ __ ] Tom Hanks he's got it like what is
his AIDS is this is this Ebola like
what's gonna happen to Tom Hank
and like a couple months later he's like
hosting SNL [ __ ] doing his David S
pumpkin like doing this I'm like you go
boy you're back but at the time it was
really freaking scary so that must have
done something to you and triggered
something to be like it ain't that bad
like how did you come to this conclusion
where you're at with coven vaccine and
all that well I mean when sorry so like
what's the specifically what's the
question no so like your dad was the
first person that quote unquote yeah I
remember famous person yeah so you
probably didn't know much about covet at
that time vaccines at that time no we
didn't have these strong opinions on
vaccines at the time well this is when
it started to to take a turn that's what
I'm asking when they when they came out
with the vaccine I thought oh okay cool
if people want to go get a vaccine
they'll be they'll be able to get a
vaccine right but then once it started
to become about no no man you you can't
work at your job if you don't get a
vaccine you you can't you you get kicked
out of the military if you don't get
your vaccine if you're a teacher you
can't go teach unless you get your
vaccine you can't go to a restaurant
unless you get your vaccine this is
going on in L.A yeah this is not here in
Florida in L.A yeah I said this is
[ __ ] insane
what what gives them the right to do
that
to force you where you can and can't go
in public spaces based on whether you
get an injection or not
that's when I spoke out about it first
but see at the time you know most people
are just living in fear
so if if if someone there's so much fear
and Chaos going on
if the [ __ ] TV screen tells them this
is a solution Don't Be Afraid get the
vaccine most people are so [ __ ] dumb
they'll just go do that
and if they want to that's their that's
their [ __ ] I'm not I'm not mad at
them if you want to go Get It Go Get It
but don't [ __ ] [ __ ] kick me out of
society if I don't want to did you feel
that like did you not were you not able
to act where you're not able to get jobs
like what were the situations that you
felt the ramifications for not being
pro-vax or even getting a vex
I mean
I
got it
I got the vaccine
I got I got it on paper I got it I got
the vaccine got it you got the so
there's no ramification yeah gotcha
what's wrong with your eye well you you
remember when Tom Cruise was doing what
one that one movie on the set where he
lost it we're following all the
guidelines and we're doing do you
remember that whole oh yeah yeah he got
freaked out on camera
[Music]
while is he doing it to show
responsibility is it really time blowing
up is it really this because he didn't
want to get the lawsuit because it was a
big mess back then and they were not
letting Hollywood work and we had no
movies and movies were being released on
Netflix so not Netflix yeah just Netflix
or Apple TV
um but people in that space it's it's a
very intro because a part of that space
is being creative right and what is a
what is the you know the core Foundation
of being creative it's being free yeah
I'm free so to me create creativity is
stemmed from
hey you know don't uh remember when you
were a kid and you're painting and you
said don't the box like uh you're doing
color inside the line color inside the
lines or do this in the creativities
what I want to do it this way I mean you
go to a place and you see a piece of art
sell them for 10 million bucks or a
million bucks you're like I'd never buy
something like this right but part of
being creative is to let loose to be
free to you know here's what I want to
do yeah and uh at the same time the
industry that's supposed to be the most
creative became so much about guidelines
and rules yeah and yeah like almost like
a religious to follow which is it's it's
a if there's any like I would have seen
military doing that because military is
what don't ask just do it yes sir take
the order you know you can't question
anything you got to kind of do that okay
fine I can see military like the buddy
who was here last week that was former I
mean listen guys I took probably 11
vaccines day one when I joined you arm
you didn't have a choice it was an
arrogant boom boom boom there were six
people on each side and you get an air
gun shot and then by the time you don't
know what bags you signed it up because
that's kind of what you're doing you're
getting shot up with all starts with you
have no idea what it is half the time
you're just signing it off when you're
18 years old 19 years old but uh it's
kind of weird to see the most creative
industry it's really weird be
disregulated yeah it's it's it's bizarre
it's bizarre so so okay for when I
talked to uh uh RFK Robert Kennedy I I'm
so curious about the Kennedy family
because Kennedy found there's certain
last names
whether the kids like it or not you're
part of that brand okay right if your
last name's Kennedy in politics you're
part of that right your last name's
Trump I'm sorry you're part of Obama
Clinton Chelsea's got no choice Chelsea
can't go say you know what I just want
to go out there and do XYZ you can't you
are a Clinton right in sports you got
Brady those kids for the rest of their
lives Dura Brady yep Jordan you're a
Jordan Gretzky how many gretzkies are
out there you're locked into those names
right the only other Hanks I know is
Merton Hanks I don't know if you
remember Merton Hanks or not 49ers 49ers
outside of that there's only one Hanks I
know so in the Hank's family okay uh
your your dad's been pretty you know but
we've all seen the goalcast video where
they tell the story about your dad and
you know I regret doing this I regret he
seems very sincere when he's talking
about certain areas of his life when
he's blown up in Hollywood was was the
family the kind of a family where at
night time you guys had real
conversations because what Kennedy told
me is in their family every night his
dad would ask so what do you think about
drugs what's wrong with cocaine being
legal what's wrong with prostitution
what's wrong with this I mean kids would
battle it out and they would debate
because that's what the identity family
dinners were all about debate that's
what it was and I love that and I love
that almost every family I saw that's
been successful they were in the
community they didn't say what age that
started it no since you were kids Wow
since you were kids they would debate
was the Hank's family a family where you
talk about serious issues or was it more
about tell us how school was today tell
us how this was today and they kind of
hit you because they're so concerned
because you know Tom Hanks is here and
we want our sons to have a regular life
what what was that like we definitely we
had we had come we we sat at the dinner
table every night you know no phones
just being present with each other and
uh yeah we talked we talked that was
like mandatory my parents you know I
mean it was no phones you know what I'm
saying
um just connecting with each other you
know like we we definitely did that um
was it connecting was it was it a debate
environment or no it wasn't well we did
a thing we did High Point low points so
we did like the the high point of our
day and the low point of our day hmm got
it I like that so what was the high
point of your day low point of the day
was there ever a uh because you know for
your debt you said you went to a
conservative School in in LA right is
that the majority of the the people the
families there were from conservative
okay was it a concert was it like a
Catholic private school it was
Episcopalian private school yes okay so
you know but it doesn't seem like but
your parents were they also religious or
not necessarily were their Church going
or no uh my mom okay my mama I was
baptized Greek Orthodox my uh my my mom
was Greek and Bulgarian her parents were
from uh my grandfather my Papu was from
Bulgaria and my Yaya my grandmother was
from Greece
and um we were Greek Orthodox Christian
um
not extremely religious but you know
it's more about family and tradition you
know it's not like you know like a fire
and brimstone kind of religion
um you know it's very laid back you know
why yes that's more about family and
tradition that's what I'm saying but I
am because your mom and dad also their
backgrounds their faith there's
differences so it's a normal thing to
have differences would you say that's
what it was or here's what we are this
is what we believe in here's what the
Hank's family does in our family we do
it doesn't sound like it was that not at
all not at all yeah I think that's
probably why I'm so out why I'm
comfortable being outspoken because I
don't feel like I have any mold that I
have to fit into I don't feel like I
like like what you mentioned about like
the trumps and the clintons and all that
uh I never felt any sort of pressure
whatsoever to uh fall in line with any
kind of mold and I I'm thankful for that
you know um you know my my pops used to
tell me like hey if you grow up in in
what you find you're passionate about is
being a [ __ ] garbage man then you
know I support you being a garbage
respect you know what I'm saying so like
my family's like really laid back like
that and and I appreciate them and I
love them a lot for that well for many
reasons I think that's very uh they're
very normal people and then they raised
me to be extremely
uh you know they raised me to be humble
okay they they they themselves are very
humble hard-working people they know the
value of hard work they work their asses
off to get to where they are
um they didn't have anything they grew
up you know dirt poor
um so they were always very conscious in
raising me very conscious of the fact
that um I was not raised like any of the
other you know kids my peers growing up
I was I was not raised like anyone can
you tell us what the uh of the other way
of being raised would be in Hollywood
where your parents are super super
famous right what was that like
well let me put it like this right
um out of all the
out of all the you know out of all my
peers I ever had growing up from you
know the time I was in kindergarten to
all the way through High School
um I was probably the least spoiled kid
that I ever met right like there were
kids you know that not had been the son
of like a successful like dentist you
know or an orthodontist that I went to
school with and they were spoiled rotten
you know what I'm saying
my parents could have spoiled me more
than anybody and I was the least spoiled
okay because they they caught they
raised me consciously knowing that if we
give this kid everything he's going to
grow up to be you know a loser or just a
piece of [ __ ] or just have no work ethic
because he's already been giving every
he's already been given everything
um it's about work that at work at work
ethic they knew if they raised me that
way then I would grow up with absolutely
zero work ethic and they were right
because the kids that I grew up with
that were raised like that they're not
doing [ __ ] you know what I'm saying they
they were correct were they did they
talk to you about
uh because I like what you said when you
said the first time you met President
Bush you went to the White House and he
asked you to question that everybody
asked you were 14 years old I want to
say I think I think you said you were
14. and he asked you so what is it like
you know being the kid of Tom Hanks and
you said the first time I had to
actually think about it and then you
gave the answer and then he said yeah me
too because my dad was also and you know
George senior right because his father
was also a president like imagine being
the shadow of a guy that the president
everyone's thinking if you're going to
be a president one day that's very much
of a yeah pressure to have which he went
through his face of party and we had him
at an event one time I interviewed him
he opened up he asked to turn off the
cameras no recording the only thing is
we gave him a recording that's at the LA
Library of Congress or whatever they
wanted to have because they they
document all that stuff but he opened up
about alcohol he opened up about every
you know he's like one day I'm sitting
at the house and
um
you know uh having drinks and I'm
sitting there saying I missed years of
my life with my kids what am I doing I
went and took all the liquor I dropped
it I said that's it I'm not having any
alcohol anymore I came back I wanted to
be a good example to my father I wanted
to be a good husband good father to my
kids he says I changed my life and then
boom he became a president and he was a
guy that used to pardon me you know he
was a guy that also went through that
but how did how did your your parents
handle the shadow because I think that's
the that's the hardest thing to do right
how do you manage the shadow where a kid
your brother's a an actor as well and he
goes and does what he does and you guys
have a different temperament your
personalities in a different way than
his but he gives you love he gives you
respect you guys are a very loving very
United Family even though you have
different opinions was there any moment
where they talked to you about your last
name and the concept of Shadow this is a
great question and this this really
touches on pretty like a pretty defining
aspect of just my entire life and my
entire story is that while my parents
did a great job in raising me and they
would raised me very consciously they're
great parents they're great people
um
they were not conscious of of they were
conscious of what it's like to be them
but they were not conscious of what it's
like to be in the shadow of them right
and I think that and that's that's
nothing against them you know I mean
they're in their position they're
dealing with all sorts of factors being
in their position you know that you
can't see what you don't see right so
because that's an entirely different
position to be in the shadows what a
point right so you you know you don't
know what you don't know right so this
like this
the the like they weren't they weren't
necessarily capable of providing me they
they they provided me a lot of guidance
in raising me but they weren't capable
of providing me guidance in in these
areas of of me just trying to figure out
how to navigate these Waters of of being
in this shadow of this Fame and being on
the periphery of it but that had nothing
to do with me right it had nothing to do
with me I'm just a [ __ ] kid trying to
trying to um you know I know that I've
been dealt to some cards and I'm just
trying to figure out how to play them
and I have no [ __ ] idea how to do it
and I and I you know the only way I
learned is through you know [ __ ] up
it's through playing them [ __ ]
terribly playing my hand terribly over
and over and over and over again right
and that's that's pretty much um
that that's kind of like my my story
right there was he and then what leads
me to today right was he on the road a
lot were they acting on the road thing
or not really it's not as many road we
my dad did work a lot but we we traveled
with him okay you know really I never
felt like oh my dad's not around oh
that's it that that never I never felt
that way like oh like my dad didn't show
up to my [ __ ] baseball game like no
none of that none of that my parents
were there they were always there right
it was just it it when my struggle
wasn't it wasn't in any lack of you know
my relationship with my parents my
struggle was my own struggle in trying
to navigate the the Waters of the world
with this in this Shadow and on this
periphery of this this Fame this huge
focal point right that really had
nothing to do with me right it had
nothing to do with me but I was a proxy
of it right and this this is this is
where I go and this is the defining
story of my life right and trying to
navigate these Waters because the nature
of those Waters the nature of those
Waters is an entirely different Beast
than the nature of the waters when
you're you you're a focal point because
of your prestige that you've earned
right when you are a focal point and
you're a goat like you said for for the
work and your talent that you've earned
in navigating the Waters of the world as
that right that's an entirely different
entirely different scenario than
navigating the Waters of the world for
someone who's a proxy of that Prestige
and that focal point but it's just there
because they were born in it
not because they did anything to earn it
that that right so like my
the reason why I say that was a you know
struggle for me is because
I mean there there are so many paradoxes
you know it's just it's just like
mind-boggling
paradoxes
is the nature of what I'm talking about
what I mean by that is
this is the ultimate Paradox right is
that
my my entire life people have always
thought when okay I walk into a room
okay
you know a 14 year old chat walks in 12
year old Chet walks into a room okay not
me we're now I'm like a public figure
and people know me for me
but take it back before them before
anyone knew me
okay 14 year old Chet walks into a room
no one knows anything about me
all they know is that I'm Tom hanks's
son yeah there's going to be immediate
assumptions okay
the Assumption right
the number one assumption
that people make
is number one I must live the life of
like Richie Rich spoiled rich kid
spoiled rich brat
number two the assumption is I think
that I'm better than everyone in the
room
that I feel that I that I truly think
that I'm superior to every single person
in that room you're a 14 year old kid
with a Target on his back before you
even step in the room before I even step
in the room and the truth was
those both of those things couldn't have
been farther from the truth I wasn't
spoiled I was blessed I was privileged
right but I wasn't spoiled there's a big
difference
I was privileged because I got to go to
I got you know I got to go to good
schools I got a great education I had a
loving family
I didn't have to I didn't have to worry
I had to you know I lived in and I had
to you know travel and do cool [ __ ]
right but I wasn't spoiled it wasn't
like here's here's your black card go
run crazy do whatever you want
you know what I'm saying here's a
freaking you know Bentley for your 16th
birthday okay you know what I mean none
of that none of that what's the most
expensive gift you ever got just so
people know did you ever get like a
brand new
uh
BMW M5 M3 when I turned 16 my first car
was a was a used uh PT Cruiser a 2002 PT
Cruiser I remember the PT Cruiser okay
yeah because and I was thankful to have
that car but by the way I assumed this
was I was thankful to have that car
because otherwise I would have to ride
the school bus okay so it wasn't like I
was stoked on the PT Cruiser can you
show what a PT Cruiser looks like
because I know exactly what this looks
like I like the PT Cruiser at the time
killing the game going back to it when
you're going through that by the way
yeah that's a PT Cruiser was it was
black
at least it wasn't purple
I'm killing the game Chad but but you
know when you when you're going through
it I know character I I watched a couple
things so a couple movies was very
interesting to watch that while you're
talking about this it took me there one
is Mark Wahlberg and Jennifer Aniston
Rockstar
do you remember the movie uh uh uh have
you seen the rock star between the two
of them so uh he's just a regular guy
all of a sudden boom he blows up and you
know the wives are in another you know
uh bus and they're on another bus and
what happens on that bus don't worry
about it you're a rock star's wife now
it's a different life you have to
understand what he's going to be doing
one day they wake up you got 20 people
remember that one scene when they're
waking I was like what the hell just
happened I said babe I don't know what
happened last night but why are all
these naked people laying around right
you don't know what's gonna happen in
that world and then Justin Bieber had
this one song that came out a couple
years ago I know I just went from Mark
Wahlberg to Justin Bieber it was called
Lonely have you put this one up 2020
when he came up with this last year I
don't know if you've heard the words or
not it's a slow song yeah but but you
you watch this and lonely is he's
telling it's a kid himself if you go to
images forget about the words go to the
images real quick and I like what he
does with this because it took me there
zoom in so that's himself when he's a
young star coming up nobody knows what
struggles he's going through
and everyone's just like hey okay you're
going to be up in 10 minutes you ready
go ahead and then he goes and he sells
to take his money's being made but they
don't know like he's trying to say I've
been lonely this entire time right as a
Justin Bieber can't do [ __ ] right if you
go to the lyrics There's Something He
says in the line about I couldn't do
[ __ ] right go back uh there's a line I
don't know zoom in a little bit zoom in
a little bit uh nobody comes in
everything because we're known no one's
listening I'm so lonely everybody
keep going down everybody and everybody
saw me sick and they're feeling no one
ear and they criticize me things I did
an idiot kid right and he's just he's
explaining look man I'm a kid I screwed
up but this is what it felt like in life
we get to pick who we marry
we get to pick our friends uh we get to
choose our career we don't get to choose
our parents and we don't get to choose
our kids we don't those are two things
we don't choose which means God chose
your parents for you and God chose you
as a kid for them yeah and but but a lot
of times when you're uh Tom Hanks uh the
out this is why like in the documentary
Captain when Derek Jeter is speaking the
one person that's undocumentary the
entire time you know who it is in the
captain documentary I don't know if you
had a chance to watch the captain
documentary Michael Jordan's in the
documentary and Michael Jordan says
around me Derek can be comfortable and
loose because we don't judge and around
Derek we feel comfortable because we're
ourselves if you notice a lot of goats
hang with each other right Tom Brady and
David Beckham are like BFFs but why do
they because who else is they understand
each other myself so for you at that
time you know when you were you like
friends with another goats kids where
somebody could under was there like an
older guy getting a hold of you so you
didn't have somebody like that's got to
be tough no because that's do you
understand what I'm asking yeah of
course that's got to be tough bro while
you're going through because every
industry has somebody that's mentoring
that guy that's going through it someone
has to sit there with the preacher's kid
and say hey I was also preachers kid
it's going to get shitty for you here's
what you're gonna deal with oh my God
you understand my pain that never
happens exactly wow never and
yeah like going back to what I was
saying about people felt like I was
Superior that uh the truth was is that I
felt massively inferior
right because I couldn't understand
because
me walking into any room you know I'm
saying back to 14 year old Chet walks
into a room well after enough times of
walking into a room and everyone [ __ ]
hates you right or everyone there's just
this animosity towards you you can't
even it's just there and you feel like
right you feel it right it's just there
well eventually you start feeling like
you don't have anything to compare it to
so you're not walking in oh I see this
person [ __ ] hates me because of their
own issues that they're projecting right
because of their own lack that they feel
within themselves because they feel
inferior so they're projecting that on
to me right I don't know you don't know
that you don't have anything to compare
that to you just think why the [ __ ] is
there must be something wrong with me
would have all this negative attention
towards me no one likes me I just want
to be someone's friend and everyone you
know like has like has it out for me
right and you I'm already you know I'm
already a sensitive dude I wear my heart
on my sleeve right so for a sensitive
person you know you know you know like
when when you walk in a room and you you
you you know or you walk by to people
and they're like
you can't tell if they looked at you or
not you think was that person talking
about me were they were they making a
joke about me and you know most people
go you know for for sometimes people
could say you know they they were they
weren't maybe they weren't you know what
I'm saying a 50 50. maybe they were
maybe they weren't I'm not going to trip
about it well in my case usually they
were right like you usually usually they
were right so that so
my paranoia of constantly feeling on
edge was off was more often than not
correct right it was correct
so that creates a whole nother Beast
because now I'm trusting like like just
just this this this like exponential
like like awareness of like social micro
interactions and and like resentment and
negativity and and gossip or or you know
what I mean just I I felt you know like
I was behind [ __ ] Enemy Lines I felt
like anywhere I went I was in hostile
[ __ ] territory right and that that is
kind of like the defining thing of kind
of like what what shaped me and kind of
created a a monster you know I I created
a whole another Beast was there no
positivity because like if there was
positivity on the people that I had
known like like that I had known since I
was a little kid right because I went to
school and I grew up with the same kids
from Like Preschool into up until High
School right so it's like when you're
when you know that the same kids from
when you're four years old they don't
give a [ __ ] that's your boy sincere I'm
saying so I was always I felt I would
only feel comfortable with people that I
felt like really solid and had like
really solid relationships with right
and those were like my brothers that
were like are you still close with them
to some of them some of them because you
gotta have but but more yeah I've always
had a base of boys you know what I'm
saying like some you know as you know
I've Through The Years you know some
people you know like drift away you know
you lose touch some people come in
because you can always as I got older I
have realized you know you can you can
tell when somebody's genuine you know
what I'm saying I can always tell when
when I when somebody is genuine they
don't give a [ __ ] I can spot that [ __ ] a
mile away people would be like you don't
understand like people are always
[ __ ] they don't want they don't want
they don't really have it like out for
your best interests I'm like I know I
can spot that [ __ ] of mine your [ __ ]
meter must be like this you know what
I'm saying I can like I'm like a [ __ ]
shark I can smell the blood like from
[ __ ] three miles away I can tell when
somebody's like so and I can also tell
when somebody is genuine right so it's
like I'm very like good with that you
know what I'm saying about your Spidey
senses yeah yeah how do you tell them
apart you said you said a lot of guys
want to uh get close to you because
they're trying to get close to your dad
you know the difference between somebody
that wants to get close to you because
they want to have a relationship with
you versus some people want to get close
to you because they want to you know get
closer to Pops how do you know the
difference between the two man
kind of just uh
kind of just like a sixth sense it's
hard to put in words it's hard to put in
words
there's red flags
um
but
I can it's hard to describe it's a
really good question I mean anytime it's
like
when someone's like talking to me
and then they're like
they say if any time anyone's saying
like if they just bring them up like
yeah you should tell your dad that I'm
like okay yeah for sure yeah I'm gonna
go tell my dad like he doesn't know you
why the [ __ ] would he care about he why
the [ __ ] would he care about that
anecdote from you you know what I'm
saying okay you just revealed yourself
you know what I'm saying like but but
that [ __ ] is like basic you know what
I'm saying like I would never even that
person would have never even fooled me
in the first place do you know what I'm
saying
it would have never even gotten that far
for me to be like duped like oh my God
you know what I'm saying it's just a
sixth sense I can smell it I can smell
it on him and you know it it uh it's
very it happens and of course like with
women it's different because you know
women probably are more interested in
you than your dad I mean well I mean but
still like even when I was growing up in
high school and [ __ ] I could like
sometimes you know like I was like 16
and there's like this like soup smoking
hot like 20 year old you know what I'm
saying I'm like a little nerdy kid but
she's all interested in me okay I wasn't
a [ __ ] I was like okay yeah she's
interested in me because of this but
[ __ ] it you know
this is something I'm cool with here we
go Chad yeah there is a difference
between a dude being like hey bro get an
idea for you're like yeah I'm good on
that dog right some hot chick especially
in your 20s and 30s you're not you're
not a dork anymore yeah exactly like you
don't like you know what you're getting
yourself into right but but you know you
know what's crazy this whole thing about
you know the first impression when
somebody sees them you know hey this is
a spoiled kid he's this he's that he's
this okay
there's a there's a part of that that
has Credence because even though we
shouldn't judge everybody judges okay I
remember a friend of mine Fernando lasso
and uh the singer yeah the singer the
famous singer which by the way he's
coming out to visit to uh Florida so
first time I get a job at Hollywood
valleys back then I was in shape and I
was like this was I wanted to be it was
my life just got out of the army I walk
in he sees me says this guy just looks
like a [ __ ] he just looks like somebody
that's arrogant that's this that's that
I'm gonna have a hard time working with
you we became best friends the guy was
one of my groomsmen am I winning some
some people are going to have that look
and they're going to say you look like
somebody that would be like that of
course and the next thing you know I
like this guy right but uh but you know
in regards to like even James Corden you
saw what happened with James Corden
recently did you hear about that or no
he's going to this one restaurant did
you see how the Balcones are did you see
this or no can you put this up so people
can see it so uh James uh James Corden
goes to this restaurant James Corden
goes to this restaurant and thank you
yeah you got it James Corden goes to
this restaurant and he starts chewing
out the actor the waitress and a waiter
twice
so the owner of the restaurant you
didn't hear about this no post the
Instagram post of what the owner said
put that up and let's read that first
the first one before he goes to the
second one it's Classic this is why
sometimes
stars get a bad reputation because of
stories like this that gets revealed
and people finally say you know what I
just
I don't want to deal with this Hollywood
star he's a headache I got pulled I
pulled him over one time he was so rude
to me as a cop you can't find it oh my
God you gotta find to see it okay right
there right there's a click on that one
and then go to the first one he posted
because it's a couple of them
that's the owner of the restaurant keep
going down let's just see if he removed
it or not okay first one right there
click on that zoom in
did this sermon restaurant okay okay he
removed it
give me give me just a minute yeah he
has another one anyway so he says to him
um
let me find it here you have to see this
one James Corden
restaurant owner
so James corden's in trouble right now
oh my but you should have seen what
happens to the point where no he's not
in big trouble at all there's there's
nothing about it that is
uh uh uh here you go I just found it I'm
gonna send it to you I'm gonna send it
to you and I'm gonna read it
so he goes to this restaurant and he's
having dinner and it's a very very
famous restaurant in New York okay
so the owner comes out and he posts he
says James Gordon is a hugely gifted
comedian but a tiny creating of a man
and the most abusive customer to my
Balthazar Services since the restaurant
opened 25 years ago I don't often 66 a
customer but today I'd 66th Cordon it
did not make me laugh here are two
examples of the funny man treatment of
my staff manager report number one and
June James Corden was here on table 61.
he's been very detailed although this
diabolical uh it happens very
occasionally in all restaurants after
eating his main course Gordon showed the
hair to baltazar manager G who was very
apologetic Gordon was extremely nasty to
G and said get us another round of
drinks this second and also take care of
all of our drinks so far this way I
write any nasty reviews to Yelp or
anything like that he says manners
report number two James Corden wants
that Balthazar with his wife on October
9th for brunch she asked for a table
outside brunch uh maitre d Ali Walters
took the party to table 301 Mr Gordon's
wife ordered a an egg yolk omelet with
uh cheese and salad a few minutes later
they received the food that James called
their server and told her that there was
a little bit of egg white mixed with egg
yolk and informed the floor manager the
kitchen remade the dish but
unfortunately send it to home fries
instead of uh send it with home fries
instead of salad that's when James
Corden began yelling like crazy to the
server you don't do your job you don't
do your job maybe I should go into the
kitchen and cook the omelet myself and
then MK the waitress was very apologetic
and brought Gordon over the table uh he
returned the dish and after that
everything was fine he gave them promo
champagne glass to smooth things out and
Gordon was pleasant to him but nasty to
the server who was shaken by it but
professional that she admitted she
decided to continue anyways so the owner
post this who owns this restaurant yeah
two days later
he posts another one and he gets a call
from Corden and Gordon calls him very
apologetic he says I have to post this
now he called he was very apologetic he
was sincere about it and I have decided
to remove and his suspension and he can
come back to the restaurant and
apparently yesterday Gordon on his Late
Show addressed this
in a very interesting way he addressed
this yesterday so
there's a reason why sometimes New York
restaurant feels very really sorry for
James James Gordon after exposing him uh
and now he's feeling sorry about it
because everyone's talking about this
but you hear these types of stories how
Hollywood star sometimes go places and
they feel like they're entitled that's
the biggest thing the feeling
entitlement so apparently uh with you
and by the way that whole story you were
talking about how you would go places
and people were looking and one day
you're like screw it I want to be this
person when he came out of the camp it's
almost like Kobe Bryant when he was
being judged constantly and I'm not
making a comparison to the late Kobe
Bryant in basketball it's the mindset if
you think I'm evil I'm gonna be evil if
you think I am this bad guy guess what
I'm going to play this role and I'm
going to play naturally I'm going to
give it to you black mamba so
psychologically it almost forces you to
play that cards very hard uh to you know
want to play a different role then you
kind of also almost want to retaliate
because you're being judged for no
reason I can't see that happening yeah
exactly to see that happen I could see
that happen so going back to the
beginning when we started talking about
the stuff uh you went right into the
politics you talked about Biden you
think things are really good right now
you think things are really okay right
now with what's going on with politics
uh are you saying that saying what do
you mean when you were talking about how
California uh is a mess I think it's a
mess yeah you said California is a mass
homelessness drugs you see syringes
everywhere I've never seen anything like
it yeah and then I said to you I said if
Biden got 81 million votes and you're
like you're thinking it's good tell me
what part of the economy is good well I
mean I think back then too I mean it was
you know like 2020 hindsight right
because that was before
um
I mean it was still kovid was still
happening but it wasn't like in full
swing right
um
their vaccine hadn't come out yet there
was no vaccine controversy right it was
just all the crazy shirt Trump was
saying
which I you know I I which I still
disagree with you know I think he I
think he could have been a much better
president if he had just been a little
bit more kind or courteous like in how
he phrased things and not being and not
being so divisive but I also kind of
look back on it and and see how you know
the media also had a big part to play in
that and just stirring up the pot
constantly
you know so just looking back on on
things but
like I said 2020 hindsight but
it's just unfortunate I think the whole
thing is unfortunate I think our entire
political climate is unfortunate like I
think it's unfortunate that people have
to choose between two extremes
I think that most people
at least more people most people I know
feel the same way I do everything I just
said they agree with me right most
people I know most people I talk to on
the street complete strangers
agree with me
you know what I'm saying but why aren't
why aren't we allowed to say this I'm
not allowed to say this well [ __ ] it I'm
gonna say it anyway
right
why aren't why aren't we allowed to say
this it's an opinion
yeah I think opinions obviously everyone
can have that however you know because I
just just for me voicing an opinion a
complete and like I said I'm [ __ ]
moderate dude right I'm moderate I'm a
moderate rational person but just for me
saying anything that doesn't fit in to
the [ __ ] left like the everything
that they encapsulate I'm this this just
me having this rational conversation is
is is is like an extreme in this point
right like this can be viewed just me
having the audacity to say the [ __ ]
truth is like is labeled as an extreme
opinion
what's extreme about it what's extreme
about saying
wow La has gone to [ __ ]
look at all these other cities the same
thing you know it's not just la la has
gone to [ __ ]
there's they're allowing open hardcore
drug usage on the streets tent cities to
build up
they're forcing people to get vaccines
there's they're pushing an agenda of
[ __ ] fear let's make everybody as
[ __ ] afraid as possible
meanwhile they're forcing people to wear
masks
okay meanwhile Gavin newsom's at the
[ __ ] Rams game he's gonna he doesn't
have a [ __ ] mask on then the picture
again this is on like [ __ ] what a
year of this mask mandate he's all
chilling with no mask on then when that
picture started to catch heat then okay
they lift the masks convenient right
because you got caught being a [ __ ]
hypocrite forcing all these people to
wear [ __ ] masks for over a year
and you don't you don't even [ __ ]
believe it yourself
right because you're at the [ __ ] Rams
game without a mask on
then once the heat gets on okay oh now
it's safe to wear a mask yeah okay right
the tents the homelessness everywhere
I feel bad for those people okay I have
sympathy my heart goes out to those
people but at what point does does the
city just go hey
you got to get this [ __ ] out of here
take the you got to move these tents
somewhere else if you don't you were
giving you this much time to get your
[ __ ] and leave if you don't we're gonna
bulldoze it if you had to go back would
you change your Vote or you'd still vote
for Biden I've never voted before in my
life you've never voted I've never voted
why is you don't think you have impact
that's one person or
why haven't you
I can't see in the family A little bit
of both you don't think your vote has I
mean I know that's like not not cool you
know it's not cool it's a privilege to
vote people die for our right to vote
I've just never voted but also in
California your boat's almost irrelevant
yeah it is I mean I've never cared
enough to actually [ __ ] register and
go down the polls I've never voted you
know I also just [ __ ] hate politics
which is funny because it doesn't seem
like it right now yeah exactly you're
very outspoken but yeah but let me push
back a little bit brother because you're
very outspoken you have very hardcore
beliefs you're not shy at all
doesn't you know voting kind of gives
you the right to be vocal if you don't
vote that's that's your right to be
vocal I'm not proud how do you grapple
with that I'm not proud of the fact that
I've never voted maybe I will vote this
next time
but that's the truth I haven't I've
never voted for anybody in my life for
anything
that's got my opinions I just have my
voice
but I feel like your voice is more
important than the vote I feel like if
more people started using their [ __ ]
voice
then uh you know
we might not be so respected I don't
know about that bro because if everyone
just talks [ __ ] but didn't vote then
then we wouldn't have it Alex yeah I see
I see your point I see your point I mean
I I ideally you should use your voice
and vote yeah right yeah exactly
especially if you have strong opinions
like the ones you do especially if uh
yeah if you're saying which because what
you just said is not very popular in the
state you're in uh and by the way what's
keeping you in California why are you
still staying in California it's my home
it's my home
I'm not going anywhere else it's my home
what needs to happen there for you to
leave nothing
I mean I'm from Iran bro and that's my
home but I'm in U.S right now so you
know I I can I can see a lot of people
who are immigrants in U.S who were born
elsewhere
yeah I mean that's a good question I
don't know I don't think I'll ever leave
I love the I I love la I love la I love
but when you see what Garcetti and
Newsome are doing there must be some
point where you're like all right
homeless everywhere mandates everywhere
just [ __ ] on the streets getting
annoying wokeism yeah at some point
you're like all right yeah like if
someone does this like you always do
this like do this do this at some point
you're gonna spazz out and freak out
right there must be a Tipping Point at
some point yeah well I guess I'm just
hoping that [ __ ] gets better
maybe if you voted yeah I mean that's
valid that's valid you know what I'm
saying I I you're like you're checking
me a little bit but but you're right
honestly right because I it's a
privilege to [ __ ] vote and I've never
and I've never utilized it so I
appreciate that here's what's gonna
happen when you vote whether you vote
left or right you're gonna walk in the
booth
and other than you know president vice
president governor there's going to be
all the props and [ __ ] yeah dude good
luck reading that good luck
understanding that a pretty educated
well-versed person
and I struggle understanding these
voting amendments whatever they are yeah
propositions struggle yeah so if you're
the average person and the way that they
word these bills and amendments and
propositions you don't know what the
hell you're walking into yeah so imagine
you're the average person you're just
checking left right up there now you're
voting for justices and yeah Congress
people you've never heard of and
director of Agriculture you're just
checking [ __ ] boxes yeah you know
it's crazy I've never had any intention
of of speaking on anything politically
coming up here today that's how it
happened I don't know where right off
the bat yeah I had no intention uh I I
try to avoid politics but you know if it
if it happens naturally then the older
you get the more it matters the older
special you got you got a daughter I
mean you got you got a you got a family
now so the way you vote impacts is there
anybody in mind you have that if they
ran in 2024 they would earn your vote I
have no idea you're not following
anything no I'm not following anything
none of you really okay so did you see
you what happened I just go off what I
see you know what I'm saying I just go
off of what I see and I call a spade a
spade can I ask you a question guys I
don't you're you're a hip-hop guy yeah
sure I mean you had a hit hit song yeah
right yeah la you're seeing what's going
on with Kanye these days okay the guy's
talking about you know having opinions
sometimes extreme opinions have extreme
consequences you see what's happening
with Kanye Adidas just dropped him this
is after you saw the sign on the 404 on
the highway basically saying we stand
with Kanye you know 405. 405. my bad
four or five okay you know Kanye is
right about the Jews these anti-Semitism
things he said he's gonna go Defcon 3 on
Jews
I mean you're talking about Kanye here
who basically look I boil it down to
music business and life so if you factor
in music as someone who understands
hip-hop and has had done music like his
music in my opinion he was on Goat
status his music has gone downhill over
the last five years or so since
graduation and all that good stuff done
to album and life of Pablo not exactly
lighting up the church as previous
um albums or review from Coachella
removed from Rolling loud CAA dropped
him Def Jam dropped him now Adidas has
dropping on me if uh doesn't no longer
work with The Gap Vogue Balenciaga the
list goes on and on and then you couple
that with the fact that you know
everything that happened with Kim it
kids you know his mom passed away
depression bipolar like all he has left
is at the seams as he bought parlor and
he's doubling down on White lives matter
and doubling down on Maga it just seems
like he's [ __ ] losing it I'm not sure
if this is a cry for help I'm not sure
if this is like he's just like burning
all bridges like it just seems he's
going down the tubes in my opinion and
this is someone that I had the utmost
respect for years ago but he's losing it
and he's doubling down on anti-Semitism
in Hollywood anyway I'm just teeing this
up for a conversation as someone who's
white your your wife is or your ex is
black I'm not I'm not married no your ex
you have a black half black half white
just like him you're in hip-hop point is
you're in La you're you're around this
culture you must have some opinions on
what Kanye's got going on right now
I honestly haven't been paying attention
to it at all no no I mean no I mean it
seems like there's always something
going on with him so it's like what else
is doing you're just tuning it out can
you zoom in into that other article you
went into go into the other article so
so zoom into that I want to see what
it's saying on the bottom of is that CNN
zoom in right there what it says under
the picture to see how they're
describing that picture right there zoom
in a little bit more a photograph shared
on verified the campaign Twitter account
of LA mayor candidate Kevin bass shows a
group of demonstrators with ban banners
showing support for rapper Kanye West
recently anti-semitic remarks on a LA
freeway overpass Saturday CNN has
blurred a portion of the image that
included a reference to a website
with anti-semitic content so what is the
reference of the way they're having
their hands being held are they are they
waving out the cars going by or are they
saying those are neo-nazis Pat these are
neo-nazis giving their waves are you
being serious what do you mean no no no
no but are you being serious that you
believe that yes you so you're being
serious to believe oh what are these
guys doing do you think they're waving
at cars in that picture God you are
those are you're just as much part of
the problem that you're just tell me
what that means I listen do you
understand how easy it is for me to pay
a hundred bucks to each of these people
to go stand there and put their hands up
and I give you 100 bucks do that for 30
seconds let me just get the picture go
home are you saying that's what's
happening all I'm saying to you is you
can't be that naive and not be skeptical
to think that during election time
anything's being used to divide the hell
out of America that's a different story
no it's not a difference you're saying
this is a political prop all I'm saying
to you is this image what this does is
it it creates emotion
okay which is what it just did to you
and it's meant to do that so it won now
you can't sit there and say I don't
really know if these people are actors
or they're real who the [ __ ] would take
that acting who the [ __ ] wouldn't take a
hundred dollars right now hundreds of
dollars to go pretend you're you know
what you can get for a hundred dollars
now wait do you you but you have to
understand this if you fully believe
that they're standing there doing this
defending Kanye a black man neo-nazis
are defending do you realize how dumb
that is to even believe that that has
nothing to do with Kanye it is the fact
that he is supporting anti-Semitism
so ants neo-nazis would support a
communist philosophy okay
Judaism and it's anti-zionist I'm not
I'm not here I'm not here that's exactly
what I'm saying I'm not defending Kanye
I'm not defeating the opposition all I'm
saying to you is
pictures produce emotions and these
people in politics are brilliant if they
want to defame anybody there are so many
creative ways to do it this is one of
them that produces emotion out of
someone like you and you have to go out
there and say Connie has lost his mind
and he's doing XYZ that's what the
position has to be Pat what there's two
separate things that are going on here
yeah there's whatever Kanye is doing
yeah whatever is doing sure
anti-messemitism Defcon free talking
[ __ ] Adidas will not cancel me Adidas
will not cancel me we'll get into here
in a minute this is my point is there
two nuances yeah Adidas will not cancel
me I can say anything I want Well turns
out Adidas just did cancel you homie
turns out what you're saying does every
precaution does that have to do with
this picture don't change subjects stay
on this picture I said specifically I'm
gonna make two points give it to me that
was point one okay point two people have
eyeballs people have eardrums they're
seeing what Kanye sang yeah these
[ __ ] scumbag neo-nazis I don't
believe they're political pawns I
actually believe they didn't get paid a
hundred dollars to go do a sea Kyle I
actually think they're taking a message
and amplifying it and showing up in La
you're part of the problem I'm part of
the problem yeah you know why you're
part of the problem please tell me why
you want me to really tell you why
you're part of me okay what what is the
whole premise behind innocent before
proving guilty right okay versus guilty
until proven innocent okay okay you know
how many let's see more images you know
how many times you ever seen these
pictures that show media's manipulation
showing someone getting stabbed and then
you open up the picture like oh [ __ ] I
didn't see this how many times an angle
of a picture like this looks like
they're flipping them off and they turn
it around they're like this do you know
how many ways there is to to produce
emotion out of people like you to say
what you just said and everyone's gonna
sit there oh my God I can't believe
that's what happened I freaking hate
Kanye you know this guy's a this is
relax guys relax you don't have all the
Intel I don't have all the Intel this
could be right but it also could be
wrong for me to say 100 this is wrong or
100 this is right I am naive I refuse to
be naive and manipulated by the same
damn media that divided America over the
last six years and now their ratings
suck because people figure their [ __ ]
out that's what I'm not willing to do
okay yeah I I think you like bringing up
a really good point because
this is my take right is that like
somebody could come in here right now
and say
hey Chet your family uh drinks
adrenochrome you do you do all you do
this that and the third you guys are you
called me every name and book they could
say the most [ __ ] vile [ __ ] to me
imaginable right
and and I could go
okay that's your opinion right I don't
need to go rally and create an entire
campaign to like ruin this [ __ ]
person who I don't give a [ __ ] about
these guys are probably because he he
stated an opinion right like
like uh [ __ ] uh Andrew Tate right
okay
you asked me how do you feel about
Andrew Tate right
well
if I say I like Andrew Tate
then I get classified as like a
misogynist
if I say I don't like Andrew Tate then
then I'm completely denying all the
intelligent things that that man has to
say here's the fact okay do I agree with
every single thing that he says does he
have some hot takes yeah he's got some
hot takes okay do I do but but here's
what people don't understand is that
like if you want to make an impact you
have to be polarizing right that's the
reason why he he
achieved so much success because he was
polarizing right
that's why he even his message he was
even a part of you know the the public
spheres because he's polarizing you have
to shake people up a little bit right
but it I don't no matter what he says I
I don't I'm not taking it personally
right I I I can I can I I how hard is it
to allow a person to speak their mind
about anything
and and and not want to then like
just go to completely start an entire
like like black ball it's like the Salem
Witch Trials to anybody can say anything
I'm not gonna [ __ ] crucify them for
stating their opinion I even if I don't
agree with it right
like what what happened to this what
what happened to this this quality of
allowing someone to just say say an
opinion or anything that's on their mind
within having to crucify them if you
disagree with them
do you know what I'm saying I know fully
what you're saying and I and I'm fully
with it all I'm saying is to folks out
there is don't be naive to jump to
conclusion what these guys do listen if
there's anybody right now Adam
tell me tell me who uh and this goes to
everybody when he goes to Kanye West
we're going to go back to Kanye West
here in a minute tell me who has high
credibility right now low credibility
right now who's trusted today so let's
go through I'll ask the question
give me a score for them from zero to
zero to ten hang on I'm gonna ask you
the question you give me the answer from
zero to ten
um
pastors zero to ten
pastors let me change the word priests
not pastors
not as high as they could have been or
should have been okay all right let's go
to the next one how about uh
um I don't know uh college football
coaches do they make positive impacts or
negative impacts on kids life for the
most part positive okay cool how about
military generals positive positive how
about uh politicians very negative very
negative okay how about the media
not trustworthy how about billionaires
in reality trustworthy
according to a lot of people
untrustworthy got it so but in reality
they're creating jobs okay I agree how
about social media virtual governments
good bad positive negative all the above
at once okay how about universities
colleges our current educational system
uh has skewed way too far left out of
everything I just said to you which one
of those has the least credibility today
politicians and then
uh I would put one universities I would
put one before politicians you know who
it is you know governments no it's media
media okay I would put media doesn't
have
credibility today okay absolutely so for
me for me to sit there and see every by
the way I just sent you a couple
different things I want you to see this
so here's what I want you to look at
okay
here's what I want you to look at I'm
going to send you these pictures and I'm
going to do an airdrop and uh uh Tyler
if you can pull these up okay that's one
of them perfect that's exactly one of
them I was sending to you just zoom in a
little bit so people can see it
from this angle looks like he's flipping
flipping them off from the other angle
looks like what so guess which one's
going to get more eyeballs why would I
use the picture on the right
use the picture on the left people are
going to look at that article more okay
go to the next one I just sent you okay
go to the next one I just sent you okay
go to the next one I just sent you
the the image I just sent you look at
this one here
can you make it uh are you getting it or
should I just text it to you
Tyler did you get it or no okay yeah I
would like to see how the media back to
the Neo-Nazi thing in La I'd like to if
you're right I will gladly on air say
that I was wrong no no but Define right
when I say if I'm right what is right
what am I saying to be right what was my
point of being right
you're saying that possibly the media
manipulated this story of neo9 I'm right
you're 100 right I'm a hundred percent
right that possibly they could use that
but you're also 100 wrong potentially no
no like maybe they were actually Nazis
100 wrong you're 100 wrong because
you're saying definitely that's
neo-nazis you're 100 wrong what I'm
saying is no this could possibly be
wrong and we have to understand look at
this here the TV you look at that image
right there it looks like a guy stabbing
another guy but you look at the picture
it doesn't look like a guy stabbing the
other guy's stabbing this guy we we
cannot be this naive today so so when
will we find out the truth then dude
some [ __ ] takes 30 years to find out
what do you talk with Russia took three
and a half years Iran what happened when
Iran took us 30 years for CIA come out
with movies to tell us what really
happened with Us's involvement in
Kissinger Carter all it took us 30 years
to figure some of this stuff out yeah
but this is a little more black but it's
not more known because these are
professionals you have to understand
when you're going up against
professionals you're an amateur compared
to mainstream media these guys wake up
in the morning saying how the hell can I
get you to get pissed off and produce
emotions that's their job yeah that's
what they do by the way rappers hip-hop
artists what song produced emotions give
me one hip-hop song that produced such
emotion that we played it when we were
working out in the 90s what was the song
hit him up hit him up produce emotions
yeah Tupac knew what he was doing it
produced emotions we're like hell yeah
okay what other song by Bone Thugs and
Harmony produce emotions we're not
against ram we're not against rampers
but we are against those thugs thugs
Thugs and we're like oh my God this is
sick that pretty good you wanted to work
out through that album more murder than
all these guys right you you have to
know these are professionals they're
professionals and we can't constantly
see stuff so now let's go back to Kanye
can you go back to that article with the
with the Adidas
do you know how much how much Adidas
lost yesterday for dropping them does
anybody know how much 200 million five
percent of uh uh five percent was a drop
off so zoom in a little bit let's read
some of this data that we have here
Adidas terminates partnership with Yi
Kanye following rappers anti-semitic
remarks the German sportswear giant had
faced pressure from public and its own
employees to cut ties Adidas said that
they would uh have a short-term negative
impact of 250 million euros on net
income in 2022 due to highly
seasonability in the fourth quarters
talent agency CAA confirmed it has
dropped Kanye as a client Monday and he
was let go by uh uh uh what's that one I
can't see it can you zoom in CAA CIA
CAA last week okay so stock that's right
creative artists agencies one of the
biggest ones damn WMA I think it's like
couple those guys up there yeah all
right so guess what Adidas supported
Colin Kaepernick stock went up I'm sorry
nice supported Colin Kaepernick stock
went up the next day Adidas drops
Kanye's stock goes down uh we can still
see Adidas being right for the decision
they made for dropping Kanye in his
positions the part with Kanye that he
kept doing
uh you know there's a phrase uh I use
when I say you know Saint status Saint
status is like when he was talking and
saying certain things and he was talking
about politics in California all I
thought about is does this affect his
dad's career and I said not really
because these are insane status it's Tom
Hanks like Hey listen man Tom Hanks is
in a movie guess what you and I are
doing on Friday night we're watching Tom
Hanks period you gotta line up with what
we got uh Saving Private Ryan one of the
most emotional movies in my life because
I joined the army Hunter and friends and
they said there's a movie coming out
you're going to be the first to see it
before the World season we sat there we
cried like a little freaking baby at the
end saying did I make my life count and
his wife's looking at him saying it's
okay babe you were in tears these guys
are going to save this guy's life price
Saving Private Ryan because what because
he's the only one that's left to
continue you got uh all these other
movies
Toy Story Catch Me If You Can Saving
Private Ryan's Things yeah he's
uncancelable he is yes he's not freaking
Tom Hanks this guy but but no but he is
in that status of goat status this is I
watch blackout for music for music he is
I watch Black Adam this weekend what
song is in Black Adam what's up Kanye's
song I Think It's called Power or power
yeah the Facebook song or The Social
Network the movie talk about timing you
come out with that movie in a way you're
kind of supporting his song at a time
like this Black Adam just came out this
weekend and the main song one of the
main songs in the movie is his this
guy's one of the greatest artists we
ever had but he thinks they can't touch
him he's Untouchable well uh
unfortunately gonna keep doing this to
him a conversation that we continually
have here is how do you remove the art
from the artist right whether that's R
Kelly whether it's Michael Jackson
whether it's freaking Kanye now you you
you can't compare those three put them
in the same category this guy didn't a
lot of people would put him in that
hip-hop category in of talent or or in
hip-hop Kanye is on Goat Mountain oh not
not with what they did with their
personal lives I'm just saying art and
Artistry I'm just saying separating the
two whether it's whatever the issue is
no no whether it's Picasso whether it's
Michael Jackson whatever the Jackson
Kelly's issues are different than
Kanye's issues bro you can't put those
he would be offended if you compare
those three yeah the point is like I'm
separating the musical Talent right from
the personal life of the person which
seems to be in a downward spiral not
Michael Jackson R Kelly status but it's
like it's like you trying to compare
some father uh uh TV dads with Bill
Cosby no Bill Cosby was a mess so the
the person what Bill Cosby did
is a different story of what he was
being accused for this guy's just being
accused for saying words that are
offensive
not what R Kelly did
not what Michael Jackson's being accused
of he parents would come over and the
kids would go upstairs saying he's going
to play with them and the parents are
downstairs eating food and hanging out
that's kind of weird fair point I'm just
I'm just saying musically gifted
as a person it seems like he is in a
goddamn Free Fall well this is like what
I was kind of trying to touch on earlier
right like I I really don't know what
Kanye said or didn't say so I I can't
really speak on it obviously
anti-Semitism semitism is terrible
obviously everybody should love
everybody obviously like gross General
generalizations on any group of people
is it is the epitome of ignorance but I
don't know what Kanye said I also know
that the media you could you could say
you know it's a nice breeze today and
the media will somehow skew it as saying
you're in the middle of a [ __ ]
hurricane you know what I'm saying it's
like this is what you're saying because
I've experienced that myself right like
when I did the Jamaican accent right you
yeah okay nobody like I was the one on
my phone like reading the comments okay
what I noticed when that happened is
that it was an outpouring of of love
like pure love from Jamaicans okay I
like it was incredible like Jamaicans
people were commenting messaging me
in Patois you know giving me so much
love and respect because they knew that
I was showing love to their culture
right it was an outpouring of love and
support from actual Jamaicans
meanwhile that it was on CNN it was on
CNN that I did the Jamaican accent and
they labeled me as as mocking Jamaican
culture and being a cultural
appropriator right so it's completely
I've I've noticed personally and I've
been personally offended by the way the
media
can can attack people and and make a
[ __ ] you know a mockery of the truth
right so I I've I've seen that firsthand
right and I I I and I take it and I took
it personally I took it personally
because I said that's not [ __ ] true
Jamaicans people from Jamaica are giving
me the most love and you're and you're
talking about all these social justice
Warriors that are labeling me a villain
for doing the accent so like
what's the [ __ ] there's a huge Bridge
here between the truth and what the
media is portraying that's a fact all
right so I think that's what you were
what you were what you were speaking on
Patrick right yeah I'm just I'm just
going to a point where so first of all
um
the comment he made is the following
comment okay Kanye West says he'll go
death Con 3 on Jews
and now remove tweets zoom in I'm a bit
sleepy tonight but when I wake up I'm
going Defcon 3 on Jewish people the
funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jews also
uh you guys have toyed with me and tried
to blackball anyone whoever opposes your
agenda
okay first of all when you're saying I'm
a bit sleepy tonight you should have
just slept instead of just tweeting that
comment out having said that uh you know
you know Elon Musk called him and they
had a conversation ticket I don't know
if you guys know this or not type in
elamas called Kanye West and he told
them hey you may want to kind of you
know in other words just chill on what
you're saying here here we go zoom in so
we can read this one here Elon Musk says
he spoke to Kanye West about
anti-semitic tweet called little lower
so Elon Musk revealed on Twitter Monday
night okay actually let's read his tweet
okay uh uh welcome back to Twitter my
friend talk to you today and express my
concern about his recent tweet which I
think he took to heart okay cool there
you have it hey you said something bad
let's talk to you don't say that again
man you're offending people what is that
all about what were you thinking when
you tweeted that out
and then you move on this will not be
the last time a human being said
something dumb
and we will also say things dumb and
when you say something dumb you're going
to want to Hope people remember how
forgetful how of forgiving you were to
not put the standards of walking on
water
because then you're going to want some
people to say hey like you remember when
Cuomo was getting canceled
and Andrew Cuomo was getting canceled
and everybody was coming after him and
he was bashing Trump for what he did and
then stories came about Andrew Cuomo
you're like oh man you acted like a
saint until now the stories are being
talked about you and now you made Trump
look like the idiot and now you're the
one that's actually being canceled and
fired as a governor where you have to
resign because of what you did dude you
may want to judge a little bit less
we're in a society where we jump to
conclusion we want to judge everybody we
hate I'm sorry I'm not a LeBron James
fan I'm not a LeBron James fan period I
don't like his policies but I have to
tell you
I have to understand that this guy was
raised without a father to make it where
he's at today where his kids love him
his sons admire him and they want to be
like him when they grow up and he named
this kid LeBron and his son decided to
change his name to brani and he was okay
with that and they're still best friends
I don't like this guy's politics but man
you gotta respect this guy as a father
so we have to sit there and say dude I
don't agree with you but I don't want to
judge you I don't want to because if I'm
judging you I'm expecting myself to be
perfect and I'm God and you're not in
there so that that was my point is that
what's so hard about
about refraining from judging a person
just because of an opinion that they
share it's like taking every single
opinion that someone says as like a
personal attack this is like the normal
now every single person is walking
around on any public figure that they
don't even [ __ ] know on anything that
comes out of their mouth they take it
personally this is a personal attack on
me and I have a right to be offended and
I have a right to join the Crusade to
[ __ ] cancel you right whereas you
could just not give a [ __ ]
what's so hard about not giving a [ __ ]
what's so hard about saying I don't
[ __ ] know that person so I can't
judge them I haven't met them I haven't
[ __ ] shook their hand I haven't
looked them in the eye before I don't
know who they are all I know it's about
a [ __ ] a word that came some words
that came out of their mouth that's not
enough criteria for me to make a
judgment on this person as a as a
[ __ ] person right this is my opinion
because like this is what I what I was
saying with Andrew Tate this is what
happened to Andrew Tate right he got
canceled as being as people making
assumptions about his character when
they don't [ __ ] know his character
right because like like you somebody can
say any like does that do I agree with
everything that he said about like like
women and [ __ ] no am I personally
offended by anything he said no because
I don't know him right but like I also
see that he's a smart man he's extremely
intelligent he has a he is he's a man he
has a six like massively successful
business online business
and then you start thing seeing like oh
well how did he do that well one of the
reasons how he did that is by being
polarizing you have to be you being
polarizing is an asset in order to stand
out on the internet and social media if
if 50 of people love you and fifty
percent of people hate you that's a
pretty good ratio that's a pretty good
ratio because you then because that
polarization is getting attention that
attention is getting some people are
going to hate you cool [ __ ] off the
people that are gonna love you are gonna
[ __ ] love you and they're your tribe
right and that's who you want so you're
you're you're you're you're broadcasting
yourself to more people to to [ __ ]
love you right
and so it's it's like
like why does that mean if he has a
controversial opinion from some from
some outtakes that are people are
posting on like of his content about
this or that why does that why does that
give the powers that be the right to to
cancel him to remove him completely to
delete him what gives them the right to
do that
so that we don't have free speech that's
what it's saying is saying we don't have
free speech it's saying if you get if if
you become so successful
if you be if you reach this level of
success and you're still voicing your
[ __ ] opinions
freely then you're gone you're gone
because if he wasn't successful no one
would even give a [ __ ] there's people
every like regular people every day that
post crazy wild [ __ ] on Instagram and no
one gives a [ __ ] because they're no
buddies yeah but if you reach this level
of success and you're making this much
money and and you're making this money
from an online business meaning on over
the Internet well if it's successful now
you're not allowed to voice an opinion
now if your voice and opinion and you're
making your money from the internet Boop
you're off the internet
you know that's [ __ ] wrong that's
wrong yeah that's way more wrong than
any like controversial opinion Andrew
Tate said about anything about like you
know women obviously like you know like
calling them [ __ ] or whatever okay
like okay I can see how people are like
that's not cool but I can also see
people like that's just how he [ __ ]
talks okay that's how he talks that's
how he talks people can talk however the
[ __ ] they want and I'm not gonna and I'm
gonna be able to sit there and go okay
well this is how this person is is
expressing himself this is how they talk
if if it's not the way I would talk who
am I to go you have to talk the way I
talk you know what I'm saying
or you don't have the right to speak if
you're not going to use the terminology
that that I that that I agree with right
that this is there where's this is like
a this is a creating a [ __ ] a world
where they're only one voice is allowed
to speak
instead of all voices are allowed to
speak and have a [ __ ] conversation
all right I hear you loud and clearly
thing we sat down with Tate for I know I
watched five six hours like I think it's
absolutely disgusting that they uh a lot
of these digital uh social governments
have have canceled him they do have
terms of services that's a whole
conversation where I think I got really
disgusting or the credit card processors
and Ubers and PayPal and Airbnb and
exactly what the [ __ ] is that what is
that that's insane to me however
circling back to Kanye you know brands
also have the ability they these aren't
they can do whatever they want with
their money Balenciaga Gap Yeezy with
Adidas they say listen we don't need
this drama in our lives we're trying to
run a business yeah and if you want like
the difference between Kanye and Andrew
Tate is Andrew take came on the scene
like boom out of nowhere in six months
he went from obscurity relative
obscurity to like literally the most
Google man like when Kanye we've been
watching this slow drip for the better
path better half of two decades bro yeah
and it's getting worse and worse and
worse and worse artists are like that
though
no but but hear me out okay for example
I'm thinking if I'm running Twitter what
am I doing with Kanye let's just say I
own Twitter and I'm Elon Musk what would
I be doing I'd probably be calling Kanye
so what he did is what I'd be doing hey
man listen
can't just say death country I
understand you can say some certain
terminology it's you can't I mean let's
let's not lose the fact that the word
death and Jews were right next to each
other in bold letters so like come on no
and I'm a Jewish person but that's not
good obviously substitute Jews for
blacks Asians but gays women death to
whatever but bro stop it let me tell you
this yeah here's a rapper saying that
let me tell you what my problem is when
a member of the Turkish Parliament says
don't forget Armenians what we did to
you we can make you disappear from the
face of the planet history books and
that's still online don't give me this
[ __ ] about those two words are used
together stay consistent not you stay
consistent social media if this to
offends you Twitter if this offends you
that ought to offends you they did
remove Kanye though but not the Turkish
they did not remove the rubber part that
guy's video is still up on history well
this is a common argument is like
Ayatollah Khomeini could be on Twitter
you cannot be what's with the double
standard correct you cannot be selective
in that area but this whole discussion
here guys got started with one thing the
discussion got started with that image
that they use that produced emotions
with you knowing what it's going to do
and to me we have to understand that
there could be a possibility that
they're using us as pawns to get people
to pin against each other all I'm saying
to you is folks whatever you get from
our podcast we're starting to get a lot
of people that get on this podcast that
don't agree with me politically and some
of you guys don't like Adam some of you
guys like Adam some of you guys don't
like my ideas some of you guys do like
it here's the point
one thing I will tell you is Left Right
Center wherever you are dude whatever
you do don't be naive it's very easy for
people from your own side to fool you
and get the right emotions out of you
because you're vested emotionally
because that's the side that you're
supporting all I'm saying to you is
don't let the media do that to you
they've divided America plenty and
they're starting to lose their business
model doesn't work people are going away
from listening to the news and they're
going to podcasters they're going to a
good reason for a good reason of course
because this is like this is becoming
the space where people actually just
speak their minds have intelligent
discussions there's not intelligent
discussions on the media
they don't there's not open conversation
that's what this is an open conversation
where where where and where where
anybody's opinion or voice is allowed
the the space to I mean this is that's
what a dialogue is the media is not
dialogue it's a singular singular
opinion that's constantly being pumped
and pumped and [ __ ] pumped
that that that has no room for anything
outside of it
yeah so so again so what they're what
they're threatened by is just yesterday
can you put up Twitter if you can bring
up Twitter Robert Reich which you know
for a lot of people if you know who
Robert Reich is he's a
socialists that economically is always
bashing capitalists constantly if he
gets a chance to do it he does it so he
posted something yesterday and I tweeted
back I responded back go go to go to
replies and that that way it'll come up
instead of the way you're going yeah go
to replies
and go up go up let's see if it'll show
it go up with one more I don't know if
it's going to show you on the third one
uh there it is that's one right there
okay go up a little bit and zoom in
perfect zoom in okay so he first show
his tweet at the bottom Robert Wright
tweet saying in 1978
CEO pay has increased 1460 percent yes
you read that correctly so don't tell me
that corporations can't afford to pay
workers higher wages and provide decent
benefits so if the average person reads
that stay on that real quick before you
go to my zoom in real close because I
don't want people to read what I said
even a little bit more go up a little
bit go up a little bit okay so average
person who reads that they say what
Wow since 1978 CEOs pay has increased by
1400 or 60 percent yes you read that
correct so don't tell me that
corporations can't afford to pay workers
Hardware doesn't provide these amount of
it what does that produce animosity
towards who CEOs animosity who else
capitalist the average person reads this
who do they hate they're disgusted by
anybody that's a capitalist so then I
pose a nice question back to him he
never responds back to my questions I
don't know why he doesn't like my
questions go up a little bit so I can
read my question Tyler if you could so
here's my question okay I said I'd like
to get your thoughts on three additional
stats average NBA player salary since
1978 has increased 9 400 percent
College tuition has increased 1400 since
1978 and last but not least you make a
hundred thousand dollars an hour for
keynote that's more than 99.9 percent of
CEOs in America should we be concerned
so then people like well
that's uh
that's interesting I didn't know NBA
players the average NBA player in 1978
was making 40 Grand a year you know what
the average NBA player salaries today
million bucks really that point eight is
the average NBA player's salary from 40
Grand are you come are you happy foreign
players making 8.8 I am I think they're
fine I don't sit there and judge them
I'm totally cool I think LeBron deserves
100 million a year not 30 million you're
40 million year college tuition has
increased 1400 percent has our
intelligence improved 1400 percent has
has the education improved that much
better are kids coming out of college
right now just so much more brilliant
than they came out in 1978. I don't know
and he's getting paid a hundred thousand
dollars to do a keynote isn't a
socialist kind of shouldn't get paid a
hundred thousand dollars shouldn't a
socialist take that hundred thousand
dollars and give a thousand dollars to
each attendee who's in the room and
divided amongst the attendees that's
what the right socialist should do but
guess what Rob is right I think I'm
happy that you're making a hundred
thousand dollars an hour I don't judge
you I don't care it doesn't bother me
but you're playing games and you're
dividing and you're not telling the
other side of the story and some people
are falling for it but not anymore
people are starting to think for
themselves and this whole concept of
thinking for yourself it's starting to
become popular and cool again because
people are comfortable questioning
things today something we stopped doing
for a few years
So Adam going back to you maybe maybe we
should continue questioning things
scene if we're right or for wrong uh I
if if it turns out that someone in the
media
planted this or politicians planted this
I will gladly apologize and say you got
me I was duped but if you look at across
the media New York Post not liberal very
right wing they're posting about this
too they're talking about this too the
Jerusalem posts a conservative Israeli
newspaper also talking about this so I
happen to think that this is a true
story but if I'm wrong I'll glad I'm
sorry but here's my question for you so
am I supposed to sit there and believe
that what they're posting they fully
know and vetted out to see The
credibility of it or are you thinking
that that you don't think that they have
to post that story so they don't seem
one-sided either they have to post it
because they're also at risk if they
don't they have to post how confident
are you that this was a planted story is
was fake no no these weren't real Nazis
they didn't say that what I'm saying to
you is you cannot fully believe what
they've done their credibility the last
six years is a [ __ ] if somebody came up
to you you're talking about the median
yes if somebody came if you're covering
the story in the actual story or two
different things no no if you're a bank
okay I have come to you
and I've asked you for six hundred
thousand dollar loan seven times
in the last seven years since 2015
you've been given it to me
seven times in a row I've defaulted
after three months would you give it to
me again or would you second guess me I
would definitely second guess okay why
are we not second guessing the media
because that's all they've been doing
for the last seven years since 2015.
since 2015 they've been playing and
toying with us you want me to all of a
sudden forgive and wake up and say oh
you guys are all right no no you you
would never divide us oh my God you
would never do that every media's
responsibilities to unite that's what
they want to do they want us to be
friends they want us to get along they
want us to coexist they don't want that
I hear you I hear you because you do
make a valid point but at the same time
isn't this as a form of nihilism
nothing's true I don't believe anything
I have to say yes everything no I'm just
I'm giving you the other side of the
equation how can I believe anything bro
you're talking my buddy said this the
newspaper said this nothing is real
you're talking to a guy that's a
Christian that's sat at church this
Sunday and my analytical mind went to a
part of the Bible that I'm you know like
I have a hard time with this I haven't
heard that my brain's going there but
and then at the end I have to come back
to Faith but that's a different
relationship with the man upstairs I may
be wrong that God doesn't exist I may be
wrong that I bought into the system
that's 2 000 years old and Jesus said a
few different words that people wrote
about it and made him seem bigger than
he was I may end up being wrong but it's
a risk I'm willing to take because
that's Faith with the man upstairs
that's a different kind of risk I'm
taking
I have zero faith in media that's a very
different story because the one here is
a different relationship the one here
has let me down one too many times for
me to sit here and Trust the media that
what they say is let me take you to the
bank and all this stuff no we need to
get a little bit what what is the whole
concept of questioning things what are
you supposed to do
what's what's wrong with questioning
things what is totally cool with that
and that's what we stand for we should
keep questioning until if they're right
you're right man hey that's a screw-up
you shouldn't have done that like Russia
of Russia this Russian Republicans
started believing that maybe he was tied
to Russia when they kept saying Russia
because they said it a million times and
then the moment they realized this whole
thing was a job by Hillary Clinton
everybody went away from it and Hillary
Clinton became the international Woman
of the Year by Forbes we're supposed to
now and now she's got a podcast going on
with Chelsea trying to Rebrand herself
because she sees an opening to
potentially having her dream become a
reality of being a president everybody's
on the chomping blocks right and
everybody's just sitting on the
sidelines and this may be my opportunity
to be a president she's at the top of
the list I'm not sitting here buying
that these guys are now reporting now
what he did say is a true tweet that's
not fake that's what he tweeted
so that part I will judge that because
it's his words that came out that we
could read all the other stuff the
division
I'm gonna sit there and say okay all
right cool I'll read this I'll read that
I'll read this let's see what happens
but I'm not going to sit there and sits
100 these guys are not playing games
behind closed doors no I'm not playing
that game we'll see what happens yeah no
you do that you're going to be in
trouble doing that because that means
you're constantly controlled by people
telling you the stories
that's not the the what is what does DD
mean what does due diligence mean
doing your homework we need to do a
little bit more of our homework yeah but
this is sort of I hear what you're
saying yeah and we're we're coming into
agreement here but the whole premise of
what I try to do is read CNN read MSNBC
read Bloomberg but then read Fox read
Wall Street Journal read Reuters and
actually formulate opinion I think what
you're saying kind of is the the whole
concept of if you if you watch the news
if you don't watch the news you're
uninformed if you watch the news you're
misinformed right
I mean isn't it kind of like that's why
I don't watch the news at all right I I
don't pay attention to you know like I
said I I'm not into politics I don't
watch the news I just go off of I form
my beliefs off of you know what I see
right and I and I feel like that kind of
is thinking for yourself because if you
only think about if you think that you
think for yourself but all you go on is
you go off of is what the news tells you
rather than you know just what your own
you know contemplation reflection you
know observation of the world around you
if you're if you're not doing that and
all you're going off of is what the news
says then I mean are you thinking for
yourself or are you just thinking about
what they're telling you but if you
don't pay attention at all to the news
and you just kind of observe everything
that happens as a third party Observer
and then based on your own contemplation
of things reflect and form your own your
opinions that to me is thinking for
yourself
yeah I mean look I they asked one time
who Denzel voted for and what was his
answer none of your business who I voted
for right because he's in Hollywood he
doesn't want to tell you but what does
none of your business really mean okay
just think about it when somebody asks
you in Hollywood who did you vote for
none of your business you know what none
of your business means right okay and
then he says where do you get your news
from and he says you know the whole
misinformed and you know uh uninformed
when you're getting your own Intel a guy
you know today it's it's it's so risky
for everybody today for us to see what
to do with the information that we're
getting I think we should stay Nimble I
think we should stay loose I think we
should study I think we should look at
what's going on what's being said and
then make a decision for yourself which
side you want to go with but I'm not
going to sit there and tell you better
believe what they're saying and let me
tell you what these guys are we have way
too much of people that whatever Tucker
Carlson says is uh really is is a
Doctrine hundred percent and whatever
Cooper Mado Joe whatever they say it's a
hundred percent this no man listen kind
of go you know study it for your own see
what the other side is saying as well
and then make a decision but uh
um yeah it's it's for me to see stuff
like this and what they're doing this is
a very weird time you're gonna see a lot
more of these stories the next 18 months
because the opportunity you got to
realize the most powerful position is
available for anybody to take you have
to replace a Biden
do you know what that means think about
if you're a Democrat what are you
thinking and you have aspirations of
being a president imagine if your name
is Newsom imagine if your name is Kamala
Harris you don't think deep down inside
she wants to be the first female
African-American president you know you
think about first female president
period think about if your name is
Hillary Clinton think about if your name
is Mark Cuban think about if your name
all these guys they're sitting there
saying man what's the Pinnacle what's
the job what are what are a couple
titles that you get in life that you're
locked in history books the president is
at the top of the list what's second to
that
actually give me a second to that
billionaire what second to that what's a
list like hey you were you know a
billionaire a superstar in sports a
super actor like I think those are some
what else would you put me those are all
great there's hundreds of them though
there's only 45 presidents you're right
what I'm saying is President is at the
top of course everything else comes
after that right okay cool
that position is kind of open you ain't
replacing somebody like Reagan you ain't
replacing a Bill Clinton that's not easy
to do those do you feel like
billionaires like Mark Cuban or Elon
Musk or or any of these you know are
even interested in being president
because it's Cuban really I think elon's
born in South Africa it's always seemed
to me that like billionaires of that
statue are like why the [ __ ] would I
want to be president well Bloomberg ran
last time what was the other guy that
ran on the Democratic party I forgot his
name John Huntsman Ryan Romney Rand he's
not a billion this past year the guy
that threw a ton of money at the
campaign Democratic candidate Tom uh
now James Lee was the governor of uh
Washington yeah I know who you're
talking about I know who you're talking
about but it just didn't have possession
by the way most of them don't 2020. they
don't must be the president no most of
them don't well what does that say you
know I it's it's because do you think it
has anything to do with just the fact
that like politics is such a dirty game
and that they know if that they run for
president you know they're just gonna
like you know have a huge just Target on
their back some of them some of them
have stuff in the closet that they don't
want to come out because it's going to
hurt their kids some of them don't want
their kids to be affected by the
constant you know Trump went from a hero
the day before he announced he's running
to becoming the biggest villain in the
history of America for what he did you
know do do I really want to do that to
my last name do you think Trump's being
invited to the same parties he was being
invited before he ran now you think
Trump's hanging out with the same people
that he know you think people in
Hollywood who took pictures with Trump
in the 80s 90s 2000s what would happen
today if major Hollywood stars got
caught taking a picture with Trump and
that circulated among social media what
would happen if you know a Ryan Gosling
got a picture next to Trump today what
would happen if Ryan Gosling had a
picture next to besos today nobody would
care if he had a picture next to Bezos
if he had a picture next to Bill Gates
okay if you had a picture next to Warren
Buffett nothing you got a picture next
to Trump today maybe a courier-ending
type of a bit more think about it it's a
world you know very well yeah so it most
billionaires are sinners and I'll stay
in my 40 000 square foot house I'll put
the nice parties I'll have good food and
be left alone and yeah enjoy myself and
you guys go at it I'll just do something
from the back end and fund this and fund
that I don't want to get myself involved
by the way there's nothing wrong with
that you've made it to billionaire
status live your life baby no there's
nothing wrong with that but there are a
lot today that see this as an
opportunity and you're gonna see people
making a run at it this is a very
opportunistic season on who's going to
make the next one for being a president
um did you did your family ever have
aspirations of stuff like that or no Dad
running or anything like that not really
he just loves the game that he's playing
that's his world yeah yeah it's just
loves his crafts and it's great it's the
Love of the Game and if you can do what
you love you're in a very
in a very unique Community because
that's the best life you can live chat
playing the game you love last question
for you bro uh you're carving your own
path in life you're your own man it's
clear right you're you're you're you
have gratitude for your family you're
blessed but you're also your own man
what do you want to be known as you said
you're 32
looking looking down the road you know
you're 35 you're 40. who will Chet Hanks
be
I'm not so much interested in who I'll
be but just who I am you know I I don't
feel that the goal is is anything out in
the dis out in the distance I feel like
it's just being fully who you are in the
present
right I think that's the uh
that's just much more uh
it's much more fulfilling
because the work is that you know
wherever you go there you are
so
the goal is to just you know the work is
is right here in front of you you know
and the reward it's not something way
out in the distance because ultimately I
just I just have
it's really just all about trusting and
and source
trusting in source in God
because if you have trust and Source
then
there's nothing uh to be apprehensive
about
there's no that there's there's nothing
that's there's not a carrot on a stick
that's like constantly out of your reach
you know what I'm saying you already
everything is happening in the now you
know
I think what you're saying is like if
you live in the past you have depression
if you live in the future of anxiety but
if you live in the moment there you are
yes yeah exactly it's a it's a great
place to be Chad tell us about your uh
your uh uh Fitness you're working on a
few different projects and I know we
have it in the in the description and in
the chat but if you don't mind sharing
with the audience some of the stuff
you're working on right now thanks for
itself Mastery Program
I uh it's look a lot of people reach out
to me because they they identify with my
struggles I've been open with my
struggles you know I'm sober today I
struggle with substance abuse for a long
time
I damn near ran my life into the ground
several times right but kind of what
I've learned is that like I was saying
earlier about you know dealing dealing
with the cards that you've been given
right is that
you could be [ __ ] up that hand for
your entire life but then once a flip
switches and you realize the right way
to play the cards you've been you've
been dealt
um you realize that you've had these
cards the whole time so my my my point
with that is that I think there's like a
a thin line between the people who you
know might like be the black sheep of
their family the people that have you
know been you know maybe like who have
[ __ ] up because there's a thin line
between that and actually those
qualities being an asset to you right
because the people that that you know
might have been the black sheep or that
have [ __ ] up are the are the Risk
Takers right they're the truth tellers
they're the people who aren't afraid to
you know venture out from the herd right
they're they're the Sheep that's not
afraid to venture out from the herd
right and to me there's a lot of value
in that as there's a lot of personal
value in in those type of individuals
right because once that once that those
qualities are channeled correctly they
could what used to make you your worst
enemy can now be your greatest asset and
this is kind of I just see as like a
matter of just getting out of your own
way right it's it's not so much a
distance that you have to travel to
become something that you aren't already
it's about clearing away all this [ __ ]
that gets in the way of you being that
the best version of yourself in the
present like like I was speaking about
being that highest version of yourself
like imagine if who you at one at some
point I just had to say to myself who
would I be if I dropped the drugs if I
dropped the booze once and for all if I
if I fully became like militantly
disciplined if I if I if I was extremely
militant on myself
to to wake up early to work out every
day to eat healthy to hit my macros so
that my training is the exertion that
I'm putting my body through is actually
going to get results because the
nutrition is 90 of it and that's what
most people get [ __ ] up on because
they'll get motivated to go to the gym
for a while and not be knowing what to
eat so they won't get any results then
they then they lose hope right so who
would who would this person be if I made
these things mandatory in my life cold
turkey from dropping everything waking
up early working out diet then you start
to get into the deeper stuff okay now
I'm taking care of my body well now how
do I take care of my mind the meditation
journaling reflection doing things of a
healthy nature to deal with all the
chatter up here in our heads right our
mental health because I mean it's at an
all-time I feel like it it's it's at an
all-time crisis especially not not just
for everybody but especially for young
men especially for men right and I think
that's why another reason why Andrew
Tate was so impactful because he had
something that was resonating with young
men right because we do struggle with
our Mental Health
so
what I what I like to say is that this
is all like truly like the answer for
all of our problems it lies within our
own self-mastery lies within the level
of self-mastery that we can uh create
within ourselves and I I and what I've
what I cut what I believe and what my
program is all about is that
Mastery of the physical
Mastery of our physical state is what
leads to Mastery of our mental state
Mastery of our mental state
is what leads the clearing up of of all
of our negative you know thinking
patterns our depression our anxiety our
fear right the the incessant chatter the
negative self-talk right clearing
clearing up our mental mastering our
mental state is what leads us to Mastery
of this our spiritual life and Mastery
of our spiritual life is simply defined
as ultimate trust in source
right so Mastery of the physical leads
to Mastery of the mental Mastery of the
mental leads to Mastery of the spiritual
Mastery of the spiritual just ultimate
trust and Source free free of all fear
right fear anxiety depression regret
fear just present right because like you
said it depression is is is having
um living in the past is living in the
past anxiety is living is is living in
the future the answer is therefore in
the present so how can we make our
presence state
as as
Connected To Source as it possibly can
be because if we're Connected To Source
then it's there it's absolute peace
there's no it's it's a still Pawn
there's not a ripple in the pond right
and I believe that the goal of
self-mastery is to live our lives is to
try to is to strive to live our lives in
that state as much as possible
it's in a flow state to live our lives
is because when you get when you start
to meditate and you get in a deep it
becomes you know more habitual to
meditate you do re have experiences
where your mind is just completely still
right there's you're just complete
conscious being there's not even a
ripple there's not uh there's not even
there's not a ripple in the water okay
it's just a Still Pond right and then
when you come at it and you can also
reach those
um reach that state and during Peak
Physical performance during exercise
when you're in a flow state where you're
not thinking it's like okay Michael
Jordan doing a layup he's not thinking
about how am I gonna that he's just
flowing he like his mind is gone he's
just in it right he's flowing right so
being being in a flow state
and I believe you know once we start to
couple these things the fitness the
meditation the things of the spiritual
nature we we realize is that that flow
State doesn't have to end when we come
out of our meditation it doesn't have to
end after our workout it starts off like
when we start working out we'll get
we'll feel really good and then after
our workout you know then we go back to
real life and we're caused and we're
back in the stress back in the fear back
in the anxiety we could have a really
powerful meditation for 30 minutes then
we wake up out of our meditation and
then work it right back into real life
the stress the anxiety I I think the
goal here the goal of self-mastery is to
through these practices which which need
to be exercised like a muscle not just
with your literal muscles but with your
mental muscles of meditation and and
connecting to a higher source right is
that what we're doing is we're
exercising our entire being to be to
live in that state so that every waking
moment right not just when you're in a
meditation or out of a meditation not
just when you're in the middle of a
workout or whether you're or after a
workout but so our entire living
experience can just be a long a a long
extended Flow State where we're we're
operating we're moving through the world
and operating within our own being free
free present and free free from anxiety
free from Fear free from stress free
from not being able to voice uh the fear
of not being able to voice our opinions
right
just being authentically us and I feel
like if if everybody could could do that
I feel like that that quality that
freedom is the ultimate high that
everybody is searching for right that is
the high that people are searching for
when when they go when they do drugs
when they when they get drunk when they
do anything right they're searching for
a for a feeling of of being in an
elevated state right and what I'm saying
is that the true high that we're all
searching for is just that that comfort
that freedom that comfort of being on
our own skin that connection to a higher
source
the a calm a calmness and a faith in
source that everything is unfolding
exactly as it should that there's
nothing to fear right that there's
nothing to be anxious about
that that that if you're stressed out
okay
you you can be stressed out about the
you know the because because when you're
an entrepreneur and you're running your
own business of course there's going to
be [ __ ] that stresses you out every day
when you're building a business and
you're an entrepreneur and it's all on
you right but to not to not to not get
it to not to allow yourself to be
stressed about whatever but to allow
these emotions to just come and go and
wash over you to not get attached to
them to not to not make these and
negative emotions your your entire the
the essence of your entire being
whatever whatever you've gone through
you know whether you're going through a
breakup and you're making that that
relationship be the the entire defining
thing of your entire existence whether
you're an entrepreneur and your your
business is struggling making that the
entire thing of your of your existence
making your your your your
um struggles with this substance you
know your your entire
the defining thing of your existence to
just
to just completely by by being sober
first first and foremost allowing
yourself to just to just without
anything without any foreign thing you
know coming to interrupt your connection
to the ultimate height so just allow
that ultimate High to Blossom which is
just living as our highest self and and
all of this is in the website like this
is this is the kind of a
commentary I'm gonna get if I because I
looked at your website right now we put
the link up there
yeah it it there's there's a lot of uh
content of that there to get me mentally
this is how it works so I create a
custom workout plan a custom nutrition
plan for each person
there's we do Zoom calls once a week so
this is these kind of conversations are
what I get into on the zoom calls
um there's a standard package where the
zoom calls are in a group and there's an
elite package where the zoom calls are
one-on-one the elite this is more like
mentorship so in the one-on-one calls we
get really deep it's just me and another
person I get to know a lot about my
clients they get to know a lot about me
and we work one-on-one directly we do a
zoom call once a week if you're
interested in joining the best way to do
it would be to go to linkage below go on
the link in my bio
um uh hanksfit.com
h-a-n-x-f-i-t you can join immediately
by selecting one of those two packages
on the standard membership this will
automatically trigger me to get an alert
that you joined which is the quickest
way to do it
um which I see I suggest what you do
because then I'll get an alert
immediately the second you join and I'll
reach out to you immediately if not and
you want to ask me some questions
beforehand then you can also go to my
website enter in and send me a text
message and a little text bubble down
there if you write your message to me
that will send me a text directly to my
phone and then I can hit you back but
I'm sure after this airs there's going
to be a lot of people reaching out to me
and I do this all myself so it might
take me a while to get back to you so if
you truly are ready to start I would
suggest just just joining automatically
from one of those two packages and then
of course if you want to extend to a a
larger package or the elite program then
then I can just prorate you for that so
yeah just here you go.com
sounds good we'll appreciate you for
coming out this was great really enjoyed
having you on the perspective of uh the
life you've lived and what you're doing
next very excited for you and uh Tyler
are we doing Podcast Thursday or no we
got Thursday and we got Friday right
Friday I think is the uh
producer of Entourage and then Thursday
is Doug Ellen's going to be on Friday
Thursday is going to be Whitney oh my
God that one's gonna be hot that one's
gonna be uh Epstein conversations right
but she wrote a book about that anyways
very much for having me oh it's been a
blast having you on man really enjoyed
it thanks for coming out thanks for
being able to take the questions I know
some of this stuff is you know you hear
the questions repetitive and it just
sometimes gets annoying some of the
stuff we talked about was fresh for the
audience and ourselves but we really
enjoyed having you on thank you have a
have a good one everybody we'll do this
again Thursday take care bye-bye